what's your favorite I did mine is being
creative oh yeah
well mine is unraveling the mysteries of
insane viral videos hello Internet
welcome to film theory the YouTube
version of your uncle who thinks that
everything is a conspiracy why yes Uncle
Bob I do think it's strange that you
never see a baby pigeon and I'm
definitely interested to hear your
theory about the government's
involvement in that please tell me more
and it's that kind of mixture of
insanity and analysis that brings us to
today's topic the independent internet
darling don't hug me I'm scared if
you're unfamiliar with dhm is it's a
series of short films with puppets that
looks to be inspired by shows like
Sesame Street but hold on there all you
neglectful parents raising your kids off
of YouTube videos if any of you are
looking it up right now to show your
children you're probably gonna want to
let me finish this sentence because each
episode of don't hug me i'm scared
features a bit of a dark turn towards
the end like arts and crafts with a real
heart or a giant can eating a duck alive
oh yeah you're in that part of YouTube
again but even though don't hug me I'm
scared is genuinely one of the weirdest
things I've watched on YouTube I really
like it it's really really well done and
you should absolutely watch it at its
core this series is all about YouTube
don't hug me i'm scared creators becky
sloan and joseph telling pretty much
started this from scratch on the sides
the first episode came out only three
months after i uploaded my first ever
episode of game theory it's a long time
ago
so i feel like we have a kindred history
but also i like it because this show
refuses to be categorized
it's got puppets but it also has
animation and a lot of different styles
and then if you wait long enough it also
has some live-action sequences all of
these different styles are one of the
things that makes it really hard to
interpret these videos aren't interested
in playing by anybody else's
and that makes it really exciting to
watch but last and probably most
importantly is the amazing attention to
detail these videos AB the number of
callbacks and easter eggs in every
episode is astounding some of them you
have to practically watch frame by frame
even see and you know that's the kind of
stuff that makes me and obviously tons
of other theorists out there really
excited there are a lot of different
ways to interpret don't hug me but today
for our first theory on this series
that's right I said first more on that
later we're gonna talk about what the
whole thing needs an overview of the
main themes of the whole series granted
we're not the first people to try and do
this YouTube and Reddit were flooded
with theories when the last episode went
up but I've really tried to do my
homework on this one and I got an
explanation for don't hug me i'm scared
that'll convince even the most skeptical
of theorists be warned comprehensive
spoilers lie ahead but then again this
entire thing is on youtube and it's just
six episodes that are between three and
eight minutes each so let's go watch it
like right now anyway y'all ready
fantastic let's get creative we're
hoping to explain what's going on and
don't hug me I'm scared we first need to
establish what kind of world work in a
lot of theories look at the bizarre
events in the series as evidence of
something sinister such as the three
main characters to whom I'll be
referring to from here on out as the red
guy the yellow guy and the doc being
stuck in purgatory or some sort of
nightmare to that I say Occam's razor my
friend a better explanation is one
that's a lot simpler
these three are just stars of a
children's television show granted it
may not be a very nice children's
television show but the evidence is
there there are several instances in
which we see the inner workings of a
television show we see clapboards and
cameras right in episode 1 at the start
of the creativity montage then again in
episode 4 when the red guy follows the
computer wired to the next room and in
episode 6 as the lamp explains dreaming
to the yellow guy we can also tell that
most of the time these characters are on
this is most obvious when duck revolts
in Episode five saying the perspective
of the video changes indicating that
duck has hit the camera that's filming
him and when the camera looks upward we
can see the characters aren't actually
in a house with a ceiling but in a
studio with lights overhead the other
obvious tip-off is that our three main
characters are basically archetypes of
what you'd see on Sesame Street's the
yellow guy is a human puppet like Bert
or Ernie the duck is an animal puppet
like snuffleupagus or Big Bird and the
red guy is some sort of humanoid monster
like a Grover Oscar the Grouch for those
aliens that go me me me me me me me me
aha aha all the time those things
utterly freaked me out by the way and if
this is indeed a TV show it would
explain some of the easter eggs we keep
seeing in later episodes as don't hug me
i'm scared progresses we start to see
some of the same props appearing over
and over again at the beginning of
episode 4 we can see a statue of Malcom
from the previous episode on the
fireplace next to the clock at the start
of episode 5 we see the number chart the
computer uses in episode 4 attached to
the refrigerator and then there are
other props like the red blue and yellow
baseball cap that keeps showing up
episode after episode these aren't just
cool Easter eggs they're there for a
reason to decorate the set with props
they've used before instead of having to
buy entirely new props and set pieces
every time this is common not just
within TV shows but also across
productions as a way to save money there
are examples of this practice all over
film and TV like the newspaper from No
Country for Old Men showing up in the
Texas Chainsaw Massacre and even better
Modern Family the armour from Starship
Troopers also makes an appearance in
Firefly or Star Trek literally reusing
an entire space station in two
completely separate productions there's
one other juicy bit of theorists bate in
episode 6 that strongly points to the
whole thing being a TV show as well when
the yellow guy's in bed looking through
a scrapbook we see a picture of the red
guy who wasn't in episode 5 except for
the credits and whose bed is empty at
the start of episode 6 wearing a
graduation cap other theorists have
suggested that this means that red guy
is a teenager who grew up and went out
to the real world but going off to
college is also a way for a television
so to explain the sudden absence of a
main character for instance at the end
of season 4 of Blue's Clues the original
host Steve announces that he's leaving
Bloo to go off to college when in
actuality that was just the show
transitioning to a new host letting
Steve go and do whatever weird artsy
films that he's working on now and no
internet he did not go off and die of a
heroin overdose he just did a TV show
like 30 years ago back to check Internet
man you guys are too hard then again we
are talking about a series of videos
where one of the puppets dies in a vat
of oil and another gets his intestines
ripped out so yeah Internet is a dark
dark place
all right great so don't hug me I'm
scared as the kids TV show awesome but
what does it mean what the heck are the
makers of the show trying to say well
the first part of this is fairly obvious
television messages that are delivered
to children are corrupting them as much
as they're helping them those episodes
of Sesame Street oh yeah leading your
kids down a dark path of rewashing
destruction I'm looking at you Big Bird
at least according to THM is you don't
think so
just look at each episode the pattern
here is pretty clear each one has a
theme you'd expect to see on a show like
Sesame Street creativity how time works
love technology and computers healthy
eating and dreams but in every instance
that message gets corrupted and not just
by decaying flesh you're catching your
dad watching porn or a human heart
covered in glitter let's take it episode
by episode episode 1 is all about the
virtues of creativity except it portrays
certain types of creativity as being
right and wrong claiming that Green
isn't a creative color and that the
yellow guy's picture of a clown deserves
to be destroyed because it's somehow
creative in the wrong way episode 2
tries to explain the concept of time but
that explanation is overly simple is
can teaches that time is important even
though kids still can't understand it
from the waves they pause the clock
answers question it's about time like a
20 inch down the red wooden stove with
weird evasive answers like time is
important I am o'clock then with the
duck finally tried to explain time
scientifically the clock yells until
yellow guy's ears literally start to
bleed in episode 3 the yellow guy learns
about love from a butterfly or bee and
it's a baby pigeon or little baby pigeon
or whatever and teaches him about
feelings but then later learns that love
is only okay when it's followed in a
certain way particularly as it applies
to religion episode 4 is all about
computers and how they can teach us a
lot about the world but at the end
simply conclude that in the digital
world people end up doing frivolous
things like fashion and shopping and
mindless entertainment they're literally
getting sucked into a computer and
distracted with all these superficial
things rather than the information they
were looking for in the first place and
in episode 5 the characters are supposed
to learn about how to eat healthfully
but the advice of the cannon meat is
confusing and contradictory and this
food pyramid is chest terrifying the
food groups can easily be sorted using
the simple health change it's also about
how certain name-brand products are good
for you and others are bad the
underlying theme here is clear the kids
show these three characters are in
throughout the entirety of don't hug
damn scared
sets out to deliver lessons about the
world but either fails miserably or
succeeds in intentionally brainwashing
kids to a specific point of view but why
why are the creators of the show so
cynical about kids programming are they
trying to say that there's some big
conspiracy behind kids TV shows yeah
actually definitely seems that way dig a
little bit deeper and there's evidence
that the show's creators are railing
against not just kids TV but the makers
of kids TV and what their goals really
are not educating kids
but in making money throughout the
series we see visuals all about earning
money such as the very first thing you
see and don't hug me a newspaper which
reads stocks flying high along with a
figure that seems to imply that the
value of the British Pound is increasing
well to have subtler clues like a board
game in the background of Episode four
that's titled money win but the most
important element of this is in a very
small detail any fan of don't hug me i'm
scared knows that each of the episodes
takes place on June 19th but what you
have to look closer to see is the year
you can actually figure it out from
episode 1 that newspaper headline about
stocks soaring in the UK has no
accidents and it's not fiction if you
look at stock records for June 19 over
the last hundred years there's one year
in particular where stock markets were
hitting record highs on that date in
1955 in 1955 stock markets all over the
world including the US and UK broke
practically every record imaginable when
the markets open and if this was good
evidence in episode 1 and episode 2 we
get our definitive proof when the clock
mentions that the past is far behind us
we see a picture of all three main
characters with the date underneath that
reads 1906 55 the 1906 part obviously
stands for June 19th
since the Brits put their date before
the month with the 55 confirming our
year but why why 1955 well 1955 was
actually a huge deal in British
television history prior to 1954 the
British Broadcasting Corporation or BBC
held a monopoly on British television
but it was 1954 that the UK passed what
became known as the television act in an
effort to bring an end to that BBC
monopoly this act led to the
establishment of the first alternative
network called
ITV
for independent TV in 1954
well the BBC is sponsored by the British
government ITV is independent and
therefore has to make its money through
advertising now in interpreting the
series other YouTube channels most
notably YouTube explained have covered
this topic but they've said in the
context of don't hug me that this was a
good evolution I see it the opposite way
and I'm pretty sure the creators of
don't hug me I'm scared
would agree and here's why this was the
first time that advertising appeared in
British television marking an inflection
point at which television went from a
medium to communicate and entertained to
a medium to make a profit thereby giving
executives and advertisers as much and
oftentimes more power than the creators
and Britain was especially sensitive to
TV advertising I mean in the u.s. we
were already used to interrupting TV
programs food ads or not even
interrupting them at all
in the US it was actually standard
practice at the time to Fleet those
regular shows into an ad so one minute
you'd be watching the Flintstones and
then all of a sudden they'd be selling
you cigarettes
Kojo or watching a game show and then
being still dishwasher detergent in the
middle one piece of evidence that was
used against ads was that in the US the
coverage of Queen Elizabeth's coronation
was interrupted by a commercial with a
dancing monkey named J Fred Muggs the
British considered advertisements like
that embarrassing and quite frankly rude
you don't interrupt their queen with a
monkey
so 1954 and 1955 were years that were
filled with debates about when and how
to allow ads onto TV and if the behavior
of Becky and Joe don't hug me i'm scared
creators is any indication the issue of
ads influencing TV is some big concern
of theirs according to the newspaper The
Guardian Becky and Joe received offers
for more main
dream sources to make episodes of don't
hug me but turn them all down and funded
the project themselves through
Kickstarter Joe pelling was quoted as
saying we wanted to keep it fairly odd
and have the freedom to keep doing
exactly what we wanted the implication
here is clear if don't hug me I'm scared
were made for television it would have
had to have been approved by other
people people whose interests would have
been for profit or popularity not about
the message of the show and when you
look at these six episodes it's pretty
clear that the message is for a positive
good inspirational entertaining kids
show are there but they've been
perverted by the influence of an outside
force don't hug me I'm scared is
ultimately a parable for the loss of
control that artists trade off when they
work on bigger screens their messages
are manipulated and their morals are
poisoned by others with ulterior motives
and with that I'm gonna have to leave
you hanging I know I know I'm sorry
I recognize that we're just starting to
scratch the surface of this series but
establishing this series as a launching
point was really important for answering
all the other questions that we haven't
gotten a chance to touch on today who
are these characters really what's the
significance of June 19 what about Roy
the ominous lurking figure
yeah and what does the ending mean but
don't worry we're getting to all those
questions and more in just another week
which means that the lesson of today is
subscribing subscribing is a good idea
if you want to see the videos when they
come out subscribe and in the meantime
remember that's just a theory of film
theory and